I'm Aoi and I'm going to be talking
about relentless forcing impact through
the gauntlet of an emerging ecosystem
because you guys live in kind of a very
very beautiful bubble so I'm going to
tell you what it's like in the wild wild
East southeast
I suppose so I suppose I should go on
with who the heck am i and as Richard
has said this is like ygl Maui this is
the professional Maui that solid-looking
Singh is the ten outstanding young men
it's very awkward award to receive
because you don't know exactly how to
hold it when you receive it and there
are a bunch of awards as well so that's
mostly what people see because that's
kind of what I want them to see but this
is what I see so I graduated 125th out
of 225 students from Philippine science
high school in 1995 it took me six years
to finish a four-year course because I
slung calculus four times and then I
proceeded to flunk physics place so I
have a grade point average of two point
six nine three is passing one is the
highest court grade in my 20s I realized
that most of the stuff I want would
actually take money because nobody would
actually give me a lightsaber for like
love of country so I decided to combine
two other things I love which is biology
and making money so I was born at heart
of maravilla that's a that's an
orphanage in the Philippines and through
no skill of my own possibly genetic
cuteness I was adopted by my father
who's a criminal he's a um a human
rights lawyer at the time of the
dictatorship in 1972 so he was thrown in
jail for human rights so from My Father
I learned something really really
important which is that when you leave a
certain sector of the country say
Mindanao in my country Paducah Kentucky
in the fill-in in the US or
Wolverhampton in the UK
you to let sub-optimal leaders to your
government so your personal virtues me
nothing
your what actually matters is not your
personal outrage or your personal
virtues it's actually public outrage
right so public outrage tempered by
civility and great love and so I
actually that's a lot to learn and that
really helped me when I started up my
business on the other side my mother and
my aunt and my grandmother I'm a third
generation entrepreneur so we started
Gregg shoes in 1939 and we make sure we
made school shoes which if you remember
and now the markers is quite a good
business to be in at the time so I'm
sort of this very radical person with
leanings towards being a money-grubbing
weasel which I'm very proud of so this
is hobby always awake what's your motto
in life we kind of model in life and I
had choose between two which is I'd
rather be ashes than dust because from
dust you are and to dust you shall
return
I don't be dust I want to be ashes I
want to like use up everything that I've
got so I'm gonna my model is like
nothing less and nothing left right when
I'm done so what do I actually do I
enable people to change the world okay
but what usually when people say that
dunno I mean what's your job I don't
have a job and I am actually I just have
passions that keep flashing pay me for
so if you asked you know how can we tag
you which is probably a better question
to ask I'm a biologist I'm an
entrepreneur I also teach I teach at the
Asian Institute of Management some
people then ask me well what do you
teach and I say students that
so clearly I'm not an interesting person
to speak with I'm an investor I'm a
gamer I'm a geek and I'm a patriot and
most of all I'm relentless I'm one of
those people who if you told me it was
impossible I would just laugh in your
face because to me as a scientist well
everything is possible what you're
actually saying is it's highly
improbable or most likely it's
incredibly difficult difficult doesn't
frighten me I will go through doors but
I'm also smart enough to know that you
can either go under the door or over the
door or I don't know open the door
because that's how doors work so you
might fit my great skill for lack of a
better word is that I was really too
young and too stupid to know that it
couldn't work when I side the company 13
years ago when I was 26 so I've had some
success you know I've only ever really
been interested in power and money and
sex but never Fame and unfortunately
that's what I've gotten in the bizarre
way the world works so I've been on TV
I've been in the newspapers I got to the
World Economic Forum and when I told my
father that he said it
wow that's impressive it's very it's
actually very hard to fool the Swiss
thanks dad so little victories - so my
dad is in the Iowa Museum in the sort of
national history as part of national
history that's his picture I have a
hologram in the mine Museum in the
Philippines so my deep apologies to the
future if this is the only thing the
ancient alien you know the aliens will
find when they blasted ourselves off the
planet and they only see like obi-wan
you're my only hope
that's me so also this is Jaime Augusto
zóbel de ayala he is one of the richest
people in my country in 2006 please
don't mention my weight I know I know I
vulcanized a bit but in 2006 this is the
Express
please stop pitching to me young lady
I'm trying to get on the stage and this
is in 2015 so I actually went from
painful politeness to vague recognition
in nine years right so that's really
cool and I'm only actually able to do
this with a really great team John is
actually in the same tie and he's on my
right over there
and this is one of the things I dislike
about the way we talk about
entrepreneurship in the Philippines
because you're always elevating the
entrepreneur as if we were Neil
Armstrong or something like you only
able you were unable to do that because
you had the right last name or the right
education or because you have the right
stuff no entrepreneurship is a skill you
can learn it and no one is actually a
self-made person you usually have four
other people or five other people it's
not like you can do much if you're just
John Lennon and Ringo isn't there -
technically black.you back you up with
the music and they suffer greatly my
team because actually this is a lot what
we're like so if any of you are gamers
this is really the wrong thing to do you
cannot be the major ushing forward
people will kill you right where is like
you know the damage dealers are in the
middle and just the healers are just we
hate you we're considering whether to
resurrect you or not right when you
clearly get killed but this is actually
what we look like when we're working so
unlike the you division person who likes
to set things on fire apparently what
I'm most proud of are two things one is
of course the team this is a team of
founders so the upper left picture
all of them are founders of hybrid I'm
all of them are shipping scholars okay
so technically the one in the middle is
a hybrid I'm in law they're getting
married next year
three of us went to Cambridge which I
still think is the best university
the UK if not the world but maybe odd to
say here in Stanford we celebrated our
eighth anniversary all of us are
teachers and entrepreneurs and actually
now starting to be investors as well we
have a horrible job Philippines is 7,500
islands we're number one in marine
biodiversity so we tend to have meetings
at waterfalls we go to the you know
beaches that are voted the best beach in
the world like six years running go to
farms and we generally help a lot of
people so in the beginning if you look
at what the ecosystem in the philippines
looks like an ecosystem where you it's a
combination between the public sector
and the private sector and at 26 when I
was lying in my pool sipping margaritas
pickling myself I said great we'll just
be here will be the elf right all the
scientists can be Santa Claus does again
not interested in to just lending in
power so I said let's just do that
but then the problem with the ecosystem
in the Philippines is that we have
islands of success that the connections
don't actually exist so in the last 13
years we just turned 13 we've trained
seven seventeen thousand four hundred
seventeen entrepreneurs we've
facilitated some investment into
Philippian companies but we've created
3,500 jobs and I'm 39 by the way so it's
almost like I created less than 100 jobs
and today was born that's pretty cool
which matches because since I was
adopted into this family I obviously
have like a Messiah Complex
as most entrepreneurs do I'm a
recovering narcissist as most founders
are around the world we've also worked
with our government we've assisted in
the development of four policies and
we've had one bill which we helped
become law which is the tech transfer
Act of 2009 that's the US that's
equivalent to the beadle Act of 1983 in
the u.s. so over 13 years in subject
being
here we ended up being mostly everywhere
partially a little bit equity we did do
some due diligence for people we do also
do some due diligence for large
incumbent firms mostly we work with
scientists and tech transfer which was
in its infancy when we started we've
done again some work with the government
and we've actually started a few
companies ourselves so what we
specialize in when you sorry if you feel
like you're going to be lied to but we
do inclusive innovations so I don't
actually do therapeutics which is like
viagra and you know many other drugs
that you see although the Philippines
has 1,000 medicinal plants if you've
ever taken Aristo myosin that was
isolated from Philippine soil bacteria
if you've ever you know had a relative
who unfortunately had cancer and had to
take paxil that was isolated from a tree
in the Philippines we have many many
natural resources that we're literally
sitting on a goldmine
so what I do is inclusive innovations
that means innovations that make a
difference in the average person's life
so the Philippine problem if you want to
encapsulate it is that we technically
compete on an advantage that is easy to
copy by other countries we're not the
only ones who can speak English very
well so across the street from where I
used to live is Verizon customer service
and Dell technical support and that's
because we're incredible vocal mimics
because I can speak American I can also
speak I can also speak English if you
could understand me better that way but
you know our natural accent is you know
we talk like this to each other you know
that's why what you're doing thank you
for coming to this presentation but
we're great vocal mimics but we're not
the only ones who can grow coconuts
either right so because we don't have
competitive advantage
what we actually do is we have to be
done price right and if you compete in
price you have to pay your people a
pittance right and if you pay people a
pittance guess what they leave every day
from my country two thousand nine
hundred people leave the International
Airport a day never to return
okay they are our teachers who go teach
in inner-city Dallas there are
scientists there are doctors there are
engineers there are nurses there are
doctors who study an extra year to
become nurses in this country 64% of all
foreign IRS's in the UK are Filipino
okay 98% of all foreigners in Ireland
are Filipino I can walk into a pub in
Ireland and speak my language and beg
people be there that are like our happy
opinions you know so now if the salaries
are so low and inflation is so high
questions people are leaving right the
the economic policy of like we're really
cheap we're really cheap for really
cheap is not working right because we
repeat and I don't know if we really
want to call ourselves cheap so what
we've really been doing for the last 39
years is boring prior to that you can't
comment what we've been doing for the
last 39 years have been guaranteeing
poverty and exporting our wealth okay so
if you want to look at the Philippine
super is like well what's the bottom of
the pyramid where you don't have the
bottom of a pyramid we're like Shakira
we have hips that don't lie ABC plus
okay so this is the wealthy this is a
rich an upper middle class 19% is the
middle class
54% is what we like to call the
political poor because they have IDs and
because they have IDs the mayor cares
about them so they get the benefit and
then the last 20% is the poorest of the
poor okay they have no ID so they have
no ID they're ninjas no income no job no
assets
you don't give bank loans to ninjas
right so
if you know what purchasing power parity
is all these people live on less than
five PPP and these people live on to
purchase two dollars purchasing power
parity that's not so good so when I say
I've created 3,500 jobs the actual
everybody else was like well that's
really all so and I'm like we have a
hundred twelve million people I have got
a ways to go um so what I'm dedicated to
turning out when we're doing is to
create high-impact enterprises now most
people know a small and medium
enterprise right like the melt in the
Stanford Shopping Center right you add
another waitress you add another you
know online shopping training pick up
order then you know yeah growth happens
and then the innovation driven
entrepreneur
every single in Mountain View period
even Zynga which I am former Zynga
addict right so you know this hockey
sticks in what I want to do is high
impact enterprises and every time I show
this to a policymaker they're like why
would we burn more lose more money and
not make as much success and I always
say the difference between this line and
this line you're going to pay because it
keeps jobs in our country okay that's
the difference of having jobs in our
country and when somebody actually says
why should I care about that I always
tell a politician because entrepreneurs
will just pay taxes the oligarchy okay
who run most of the companies in the
Philippines they're going to pay taxes
wherever it's convenient
usually in became an island or BVI right
people like me with a team of five we're
just really trying to build a scalable
repeatable business model we have no
time to look for tax loopholes we're
just going to pay it
and the more of us there are not looking
right like the average person the first
time they get a job who the heck is FICA
right who's who's taking my money I work
hard for this it's the government we're
not going to care we're like right let's
just do this let's just do this and try
to make a difference so it turns out and
every insight has found all over the
world that every time you have one
percent rise in mean income or
consumption expenditures you actually
have a three percent reduction in the
proportion of people below the poverty
line give someone one percent more in
disposable income and you reduce the
number of people who are poor and what
people don't really realize is last year
alone in 2016 like 350,000 people around
the world came out of poverty and that
doesn't sell that news doesn't sell
right so if you saw 2016 was a bad year
not for 350,000 people around the world
okay and that's because if you have a
micro-enterprise
the most I'm going to be able to hire is
maybe two to three people and you
restaurant 20 to 30 jobs but if you have
an SME based on an innovation that can
scale you usually create 220 to 230 jobs
and everybody knows what this slide is
this is the global global goals but
everybody has agreed on that we need to
work on right so what I'm doing for the
global goals especially what I think is
important in the ASEAN region is that
not just combining technology
development with business development so
basically putting the geeks and the
money-grubbing weasels together and then
making money off their love uh-hum I
want some buying that with community
development so that it makes a
difference in the average person's life
a lot of people measure GDP GDP is like
measuring GDP is like trying to diagnose
someone's heart disease by looking at
the engine of their car so to me it's
not actually a great surrogate indicator
of how people are feeling and therefore
how they're going to vote and what
people needs are so I looked at have
rige average household net worth or
increase in average household income
because technically that's what matters
so where should we be doing this
inclusive innovations before I give you
examples of what I do where should we be
innovating well everywhere everywhere
our problems in each ecosystem are
unique diverse and complex every country
needs to innovate and then we've got to
share our models so that we can find
common solutions to global problems and
it's already happening except that some
innovations are born in the wrong place
and they usually aren't visible enough
the public and private funders right I
mean who knows I was very surprised
several years ago to learn that Skype
was invented in Estonia right the
ballpoint pen was invented in Argentina
okay but if it's not Silicon Valley it's
not gene town on the upper side the
coast it's not in London it's not an
American valley in Scandinavia and it's
not in Singapore people don't realize
that these opportunities exist and then
they're the Silicon Valley myth
mythology and the world intention things
people from the valley tend to do when
they come to my country
the first one is West splaining you guys
ever hear of mansplaining that's what
happens when men talk over women right
what people like to do when they come to
my country is they West's plane right
they sort of talk over us and say this
is the way we do it in the valley okay
it's not you know this ain't the valley
right have you noticed um - sometimes
you have Bungie Mentors
right they'll come in they'll give great
advice mwah
right good that they bungee out and
three you guys hide your own digital
divide right there's a digital divide in
Silicon Valley and I know exactly where
it is this is the 101 on the west side
seven year-olds are coding and on the
right side not so much right and I can
say there's a digital divide on El
Camino as well right so
in fact a lot of social entrepreneurs
from the valley have said you know what
we don't really need to go
to developing countries we can try and
pilot it here around us and then we'll
work in developing countries we can get
traction here but the greatest sin of
Silicon Valley is not that you make it
seem easy it's that you make it seem
fast and it's not like the great Silicon
Valley tour is to go to schlock Lee's
garage which apparently now is a Mexican
grocery store right but that's where
kleiner worked a noise and Gordon Moore
and they all went to start Fairfield
semiconductors right
Packard garages around here it took a
long time to build this ecosystem and
you can't tell everybody of everybody
else to Eastern Europe and other
countries that oh no it's like this we
just did this and like boom took a long
while right
so how should we innovate well first
it's not about the money when we deal
with scientists and even artists you
know nobody goes into science to make
money that's not going to the priesthood
to meet girls okay also Gandalf never
did it for the money right leonidas of
the 300 never did it for the money so
you if you sister late they feel like
they're selling out right but it is
about the money oh it really is about
the money because the cost of the global
goals are expensive right for
governments for businesses and people
but you know really the alternative is
death and aside from Gandalf and
supposedly Jesus Christ most evidence
says it's permanent right
there have to be innovations in the way
we also choose to make money so business
model innovations as well and governance
innovations right and this is my
favorite quote from the Philippine
Statesman because this is what I always
tell my students about how we should
innovate or why and this and this is
from a colleague of my father she said
why be honest when it pays to be
dishonest why fight for others where
they won't fight for you or even for
themselves why think for yourself
when it's easier to let others think for
you well the answer lies in what life
means to you if life means having a good
time
money fame power security things you
don't need principles all you need are
techniques if we're serious about the
global goals as a species because there
is only one race and that's the human
race if because when people say save the
earth I find that very funny as a
biologist because the earth is going to
shrug us off like a bad cold seriously
we are a disease that's killing it of
course then I try and kill us back what
the message should be save the humans
right so if you're here to change the
world so you cannot just have techniques
the techniques are useful but the
principles are better so I'm going to
talk a little bit about why an
innovation ecosystem has to work because
innovation is everyone's responsibility
so in the beginning academia has a
really really cool idea and then
investors take that idea out of the
university put a little bit of money
around it and then they give it to
entrepreneurs those entrepreneurs with
the same small resources are supposed to
grow that idea eventually they're
acquired by corporations who make even
you know who scale it up have
distribution get it to the most people
possible ok these guys create the market
these guys increase it and then there's
a government every time I say to any
government in any country this is what I
say please take note you are not holding
the plant ok you are holding us your job
is to create an enabling environment so
innovation can happen cage don't touch
the plant just help us
don't touch the plant keep your hands
off the plant precious hmm so really you
have to let it go to move forward and
the problem with the ecosystem is that
have you ever seen one of these raises
is not like the other guy is just you
know boy
hey hey hey I said if I said no the
other guys run it right because you have
to keep pace with you know the person is
going to pass him the baton now in most
countries in Southeast Asia
everybody wants National Economic
Development right everybody wants more
money everybody wants more impact
nobody wants poverty around or crime or
whatnot except that you're all in the
same boat and everybody's growing in
different directions so you just stay
put so you don't let it go to move
forward and radical collaboration and
radical candor and in this post truth
age radical civility is the only thing
that's actually going to make a
difference so why is the Philippines
messed up one I've already mentioned our
the ecosystem is like our geography okay
we have islands of success that are not
connected to our people our teenagers
we have freedoms we abuse and
responsibilities we refuse to shoulder
number three like most of the developing
world our innovation is like teenage sex
you don't know what it is we say we have
it we know you want more of it and
everybody else is lying to each other
we're like oh we're so innovative dude
like I had innovation last night right
yo mama no I mean you know no one knows
what they're talking about right
it's like love sorry well what do you
think love is oh it depends if we can't
define it we can't measure it we can't
measure it it won't happen okay that's a
basic management Dennett so let me give
you a whirlwind tour of my country in
academia this is the attitude what do we
want evidence-based changed when do we
want it after peer review right
so there's a calm there's a smell it has
to be a compromise between speed and
rigor okay
State University R&B isn't rippling out
to the public the core of it when this
number is in the center is the number of
peer-reviewed publications this is the
publication impact rating so anything
over one is better than the global
average anything less than one is less
than the global average then you have
viable patents most university
just measure these three circles what
we've done is we've added the outer
circles because that effect that's where
it reaches and makes a difference in
someone else's everyday life this is the
University of the Philippines Diliman
dear how to rippled out they've got some
interview publications better than the
global average 18 viable patents no
patents license no revenue created UB
Manila 20 million pesos that's about Oh
divided by 50 what is that
need four million no not lot not a lot
right and then university to it because
bad news which mostly is agriculture has
47 million although it has less
publication impact rating and this is
not their fault it's not their fault
because the way the universe state
universities have been set up is that
you need 20 signatories all the way to
the Board of Regents for not for a
nondisclosure agreement
so forget actual technology transfer you
can actually get a you can actually get
a contract sign it'll take months but if
you look at private universities in the
region such as the University of San
Carlos where they're so below the world
average they only have 177 peer-reviewed
publications but they actually make a
difference in people's lives
right that's like 10 million dollars I
think I'm really bad at math by the way
I said this beginning right but I just
divided by 50 I should have done this
for you four million excellent she could
have a finance person in the audience at
four million dollars that's a lot okay
and why had that worked for them because
they have a tech transfer office that
has spun out from one department this is
only the revenue from one department it
it's 100 percent owned by the university
if the people who work there don't
perform well they can get fired right
and there's only one person you have to
talk to it's a literal one-stop shop
so and unfortunately state university
rules in the Philippines forbid the
government-owned universities where a
lot of our good research is also stuck
from ever doing the same thing okay and
what's the problem that is plaguing
Filipino scientists first of all our
scientists are asked to do 300,000
things as we like to say in the
Philippines all at a time we don't like
doing one at a time that's boring we do
it all at a time right so they're asked
to teach okay they're asked to do
research okay they're asked to publish
that research publish or perish they're
asked to make patents they're asked to
commercialize that research they're also
called
by radio stations and TV TV stations to
explain basic science because it's
really easy to rule over people who
aren't scientifically literate and
that's why our government keeps most of
our country scientifically illiterate
illiterate so they do get these calls
from radio stations like there was a
baby born completely white oh you mean
like an albino mm-hmm is that a fairy
you call the Philippine genome standard
No now that's albinism what like never
mind
so they have to do all these things how
can you ask them to and by the way they
also get paid a pittance they're also
strangled by a thicket of archaic laws
and policies which we're trying to fix
and also the top six universities in the
Philippines operate with only 20% of the
rnd budget of our Sen neighbors so in a
way it's kind of miraculous that we get
to do all this stuff anyway
and unless it of the investors so the
investors you guys have heard about the
value of death right government funds
the research and then you have seed
funds angels and venture capital and
then there's a value of death for
development and this is true of our
software industry in the Philippines
which you've already heard about but for
the life sciences which is what we do
and for biotech in general we like to
call
see abyss this is where our dreams go to
die in fact it's so bad there that we
feel like we're getting waterboarded and
so we pray for death it's like that
abyss is filled with Dementors now in
the US you guys actually have SBIR
grants those are small bit in small
business innovation research grants and
stimulus funds in every state ok almost
in every city and you know in the
Philippines we have fantasies about an
SBIR grant one of these days we'd like
to see it and the pony and the Ferrari
so Filipino angel investors they're
usually omg's their old mainstream guys
they've made their money in retail and
real estate ok so to ask them to invest
in something that's going to burn money
for three years at minimum even if
you're going to make like 100x return
they're like ah why not just go
franchise the McDonald's and then
they're the CEOs child of owner ok now
this is usually convenient because
they're usually the kids of the OMGs and
so they have daddy or mommy issues
right so they they understand the tech
they have some budget which of course
the OMGs think that you're here it's
like giving somebody their first car I
know you're going to wreck it so I'm not
going to give you a great car but that's
some money that can go a long way in the
Philippines they're also very myopic
because they're risk-averse so there's a
bias to giving debt instead of equity
because they don't share the risk there
are also no good models about angel
investments so it's really they need an
archangel Network and a couple of
cherubs to do the analysis right and
deal structure management and then there
the VCS first they have to deal with
limited partners who are old mainstream
guys too there's really no deal fro from
the value of death much less from the
abyss and 3 they still need an archangel
network and a couple of cherubs because
there aren't too many people doing this
in the Philippines either and this is
true actually of most of Southeast Asia
if you look say
our neighbors and you look at the number
of venture capital firms you'd see a lot
but if you actually looked if you
actually counted how many of those firms
invest more or at least 30 percent of
their portfolio in their own country you
maybe get six out of 100 right because
there's lack of deal flow and then let's
go to our entrepreneurs in the
Philippines we are the number what we
are number one in the region for number
of businesses started
we're very entrepreneurial we're also
number one in the region for a number of
businesses closed and that's because the
poor profitability that's a bad business
model like say ice for rent could I told
you that was bad and also lack of access
to capital and if you look at philippine
startups by sector 83 percent of them
are service and they're serving you guys
for three percent are manufacturing 4%
is extractive which means farming and
mining and then there's the other 10%
what does the other 10% look like there
are 100 software and mobile app startups
and the largest investment closed for
you hop with 7.4 million u.s. dollars in
tech there are 15 life science startups
and the largest investment close and
you're right Christina it is 4.4 million
dollars for for that University I just
mentioned and there are 74 social
enterprises and Cebu not Manila the
capital city was named as one of the top
six top alternative to Silicon Valley by
Entrepreneur Magazine to start a
business in the world there are two
kinds of founders are millennial tech
founders who really just need co-working
space and someone sometimes do puncture
their delusions of adequacy and the
academic founders who are shall we say a
little bit older a little bit more jaded
and they're really really really really
beep nerds they're like the Sheldon's of
the world so but you thinking
working with them is like herding cats
if you like cats it's a pleasure but you
know they're really not meant to be
herded certainly not by you but it's fun
I mean for me and then corporations
corporations really they don't know what
they can buy those in corporations like
to import mature technology not reverse
engineer it right and they just like
investing in startups over you and then
there's the government ah so some of it
the government is really dedicated to
the public good but they have such shall
we say some misconceptions one is that
they don't realize it open doesn't mean
free so open-source doesn't mean free
and free doesn't mean free there are two
meanings are free one is a right the
other is without cost and sometimes they
want to give some open source thing
completely for free so I have to tell
them no matter how hungry somebody was
if I stood outside the subway station
with a VAT full of free rice no one
would take it because people would be
like why are you giving away free rice
what's wrong with it so you have to
charge a minimal cost at the very least
number three they actually think that
the private sector is evil and sometimes
it is but not everybody right so they
always seem like well we have to invest
in the good of the Filipino people like
I'm Silva Pino and I make money but why
not invest in me well but you're the
private sector I'm like I pay taxes okay
I should get that
um it's not all their fault because the
private sector should stop whining and
grab an oar and after utilize that
rigidity is a natural consequence of
scale you're going to have some
bureaucracy right so the the private
sector actually doesn't help the
government either right if you're not
talking nothing gets done and it's the
same thing even here would self
in cars technology is always a
revolution governance is an evolution
and so I'm not saying we should not have
government be proactive and just
regulate the heck out of stuff that's
wrong it's just like jazz
you should jam together right like talk
to each other so to fix that we're
actually starting to work on the startup
bill and the equity crowdfunding bill
we're trying to get that every time we
work on these Senate hearings it costs
us around $5,000 a day because that's
how much we would have been paid how to
be working for been working for another
client so it does cost us that IB dime
to work with the government but we think
of it as a long-term place and the
ecosystem is actually changing as well
since we had the tech transfer act the
intellectual property office of the
Philippines is placed 90 service offices
where people can do patent searches and
file patents but not where people will
actually talk to customers which is kind
of the point um we have great things
that survived the abyss though so one of
them is our n8m corporation it's a
portmanteau of Ari and Nina or mother
son and the mother that one box is good
for one hectares and the yield
difference in corn is one metric ton per
hectare they wanted to help Filipino
farmers they actually ended up helping
up helping out Dubai and Singapore
because in Dubai you want the you know
it's a desert you need this the reason
the yield is bigger is because instead
of having six roots the plant has like
sixty roots so this is great in a
drought because it sucks up more water
and nutrients and it's great for us in
the Philippines where we get hit by an
average of 20 typhoons a year because
the fact the plants stay up so this has
patents in India Australia and I think
the u.s. is coming up as well so bring
it to California soon so one it's about
four four hundred fifty pesos that's
like ten dollars about
and it's good for one hipster
so the huge four million dollar
investment in the life sciences comes
from the University of San Carlos they
have the first mango waste bio refinery
if you've ever tried our dried mangoes
from the Philippines please pass by the
obesity or Hayward anytime we have great
dried mangoes there drugs you will eat
one of them and then your life will
never be the same but the problem is
that industry they sell out the peel in
the seat and that's throwing out a lot
of money because what that bio waste
refinery does is that the low value
products which is the seed husk we sell
as biomass to SEM X and Lafarge so
cement companies for their boilers
intermediate value stuff is flour oil
key the flour is gluten free obviously
because it's not wheat um the oil is
also good not just for making mango
butter like mango butter to eat with but
mango butter like shea butter and cocoa
butter and if you've never been to a
Sephora you should go just to see the
mob of people there and what crazy
people will buy for beauty right so we
think beauty is a great market and in
bulk the pectin think which is the keen
reagent for all of your gummies and the
polyphenols which are antioxidants keep
us breathing firm or low for longer and
again beauty they go anywhere from 600
to 1200 dollars per kilo the plant
opened up in January 2015 by January and
December 2015 by January 2016 the next
month I had a purchase order from Mexico
and a licensing deal from South Africa
and as far as social impact is concerned
fifty former garbage scavengers were
employed and housed near that bio
refinery so coming to the end these are
just examples of the things that we work
on in the Philippines what we're doing
now talking about scavengers this is
bicycle this is
- Mountain right so all these people
around scavenge in that trash Mountain
okay
that's the poorest of the poor some of
them are political poor because they
have IDs so we want to eradicate poverty
in our country in ten years and how do
we do that now usually when you have a
this is global goal number one no
poverty how do you do that well usually
government invests in social and
physical infrastructure and that's
poverty alleviation the private sector
invest in corporate social
responsibility corporate shared value
social enterprise is a nice property
reduction but there's an elephant in the
room you know who that elephant is it's
the poor if support has anyone asked the
poor why there what you can't have the
poor why they're poor they'll just ask
for more money no why do we think what
is the paradigm that poor people are
empty vessels into which roof resources
have to be poured into actually the poor
poor people are like soda bottles that
you've shaped in so much and then Jam
the pack of mentos into it right all
social change happens from the kernel of
people who are disenfranchised and
depressed and if you don't want that
social change to be bad you have to help
them out so the only way you can do that
is by eliminating poverty okay so how
are we going to do that what we've done
is we've partnered with an organization
called lab pH lab dot pH was started by
six total Haas dr. Rojas is 89 he's a
Warren Buffett of the Philippines he is
a development banker before it was
called development banking and so there
are three arms of lab dot pH one is tak
one is social and we manage the
cacophony of the life sciences so
project zero of the tech arm is now part
where were lab dot pH is partnered with
all 255 congressional districts in the
Philippines so project zero of the tech
arm is called Quicksilver it's a
satellite we're launching it into space
it's now the national broadband provider
so we have the most expensive and the
slowest internet in all of Southeast
Asia and now we won't because we'll have
satellite internet so this whole last
mile thing only works when you're Russia
or America we are Islands you're island
people this is why I'm wearing a
sweatshirt even though you guys are
insurance this is gold for me right so
when you give people Internet
that means they can have IDs when they
have IDs they can a bags out on the back
of cops you generate ecommerce also you
build communities right your Dutch with
all the communities you get big data you
get their infrastructure needs and so
you have a bunch of requirements which
you can't add by the global goals and
then ask grants from people like USAID
and all these other places but you're
also going to get a bunch of
opportunities right not problems
opportunities never waste a good crisis
right so we would then only fund things
that were part that solve these
opportunities because what is in one
district could be a problem in another
district okay so and the way we do that
is that dr. Rojas has actually distilled
all the sixty years of experience to a
community accounting system and a canvas
just like the business model canvas only
like three hundred times more
complicated and it does have a triple
bottom line biocapacity social equity
meaning household net worth and income
and ecological footprint so we can
measure sustainable development we can
figure out if you take you have the
marine waters and if you have household
consumption right that if you're
importing seven million dollars worth of
rice every year right what does that do
how does it affect everything else so
one of our key projects under lab pH is
in the island of marine Dookie just by
bringing modern agricultural techniques
to this island we will save them seven
million dollars a year that impacts
100,000 people right
I'm just bringing the boxes of
bio-fertilizer there dude it's not
rocket science
these are things that already exist so
hybrid I'm is going to die a natural
death and it's going to become ignite
because when I founded hybrid I'm I
founded it to die maybe a better way to
say it is that like wanting a baby that
you get a dog I love the dog but I came
back from grad school I said I want to
invest in my country when things go
wrong and in a country a patriot doubles
down they don't move somewhere else they
say I had a choice I have a choice I
don't have to leave right 3,000 people
are leaving a day I don't have to leave
I'm going to come back ok and I'm going
to do things that make a difference so
I'm going to invest in there's nothing
to invest in ok so I'm gonna start a
consulting company it's been 13 years
that's great
3,500 jobs great great want to be the
pretty girl in the room now I'm tired of
asking old mainstream guys please invest
in this it's a beautiful technology it
will help the country it'll make you 300
times your money back and incidentally
it's good for the environment
no franchising on McDonald's so I'm
actually going to put my money where my
mouth is gonna start investing so
there's the life science arm the tech
arm and the social island of course the
others who just want to invest in
whichever global goals they like someone
who's passionate about water will just
invest in cleaning up our waterways and
so on and so forth so it's nice which is
what we're going to turn into is
basically a startup studio model so this
is we're going to actually take 10 teams
of to one tech at one business and then
we're going to pay them we're going to
pay them to work for their own idea
because the number one thing that stops
a young Filipino from starting up a
business is because they're supporting
the education of a sibling they're
giving money to their mom's health care
right so they can actually earn peanuts
right you have to
give them a salary so we're going to
give them a salary and you say you're
not working on your idea you have a year
to do that right and at this point
because technically we're employing them
right at this point you spin out the
company okay and out of those ten we
would invest in a seed round and three
companies of $100,000 per side up then
we do one company at five hundred
thousand US dollars for that one startup
and then of course the returns would
feed back into the incubator / startup
studio and we would actually Scout like
professional sports teams we're not just
going to sit pretty like the pretty girl
in the bar and wait for guys to come up
to us because it may look strange if you
look at my body now but once I want the
pretty girl in the bar and just waiting
there sometimes suboptimal people come
up to you in the bar and I'd rather
Scout like professional sport teams and
find out
that's the player I want you know make a
pitch to him so this is because we
believe that startup should be painful
but not fatal and at this point starting
a life science startup in the
Philippines is fatal it's fatal to a
marriage it's fatal to a family because
they cannot afford that loss of income
okay but I don't want to remove the pain
because then I'm going to get ground
true preneur you entrepreneurs are there
are the guys who keep joining business
plan competitions to get prizes or get
grants from the government and they
don't actually make anything right you
have to build something to be an
entrepreneur so our goal is to create
10,000 jobs in ten years we're not
interested in making our first million
we want to impact our first million and
so we were going to create jobs for
2,000 highly skilled people these are
scientists engineers and managers 3,000
semi sales jobs which are farm managers
or lab techs our fabricators five
thousand unskilled jobs which are our
farmers our aquaculture as' and former
scavengers and these innovations are
going to serve millions of people in my
country
and rock it out throughout the rest of
the region because of a.cian integration
and that's what I do thank you very much
thank you for a really you know frank
and entertaining presentation before we
get into Q&A I want to recognize
Christina Laskowski who came there she
is the callsign it was thanks to
Christina that we got introduced and
Christina is the president of the
Science and Technology Advisory Council
of Silicon Valley which advises
Philippine government on S&T and
innovation issues can I say that would
you say a word we've looked at the
entire ecosystem may really serve as a
bridge between the Philippines Southeast
Asia now and Silicon Valley for a
non-profit 501 C 3 comprised mainly of
fill em either tech professionals or
professionals with the science arena and
our motivation is shifts to help the
country and the region and there's a lot
of alignment because our our process is
really focused on a holistic approach to
entrepreneurship as well so thank you
very much oh so I get to ask first
question okay and I want to go into this
West plain oh yes
so what are some typical West plain
content things that people here so you
should do in the Philippines and and
they just don't work well first of all
whenever I usually tell somebody that
we're paying people um - so that they
can quit their jobs they're like oh no
that's going to just create great issues
you didn't make the light enters wait
for that I have to go build something
I'm learning okay that's gonna hurt and
that's not just going to hurt them right
so again it's like the worst landing
happens when you don't take the time to
understand the ecosystem what you're
going into
and treating that with respect so
because not everything is going to work
the way works in the valley right yeah
so that's the kind of thing so one is
what
you paid our salaries to people at the
very beginning of the company right you
know okay because they can be fired
right that's right you can saw notice
that you said that these people are your
employees during this period so that's
also you know how do you have more than
just influence right I think that here
in the valley you get a lot of this from
boards right oh when a company gets the
board then there's the threat that the
board can fire the founder yes and so
you've taken that to an even earlier
stage sure no it's just reward and
Punishment okay or don't know right you
know your proposal not just kicks the
puppy you don't want a party you just
want to perfect
so by dog is other than I'm sweetness
and light what's over before questions
colors violent reaction
it's so nice light they all had a very
emotional system life sciences countries
you showed on your slide what kind of
Life Sciences technologies are they
working on you can make me eggs so it's
not mainly I'll we have a thousand
medicinal plants right and we have
untold numbers of bacteria actually
there's a reason why SARS never hit the
Philippines it's because they took one
look at our bacteria and they said oh my
god not in the face I'll go back to Hong
Kong just don't hurt me
so there's a lot of people working on
stuff it could be therapeutic but
because most investors are risk averse
they're going the nutraceutical
cosmeceutical route but it's it's really
something that could help many people
but it it just cells to say it's an
antioxidant so you have a bunch of
people doing anti inflammatory stuff
that could really hurt I hurt arthritis
and they're selling it as anti-wrinkle
and they make more money that way
because that's the only way they're
going to put food on the table and keep
the lights on so so there is health
stuff
there's a lot of Agra stuff there's a
lot of industrial stuff as well but it's
it's very hard to find the industrial
biotech stuff because then you have to
go to one of the old mainstream guys and
the only way you get to convince them
quite frankly as you say hmm you know
it's cheaper than bribing the government
inspector everyday because he knows your
stuff that works that's why you keeping
coming back right so if you have more
ties that overtime this actually works
so it's actually harder to say to lead
with it's good for the environment so
and and there's a lot of scientists we
have brain drain severe brains in all
the time it's it's more like I'm going
to get this under my belt and then leave
to go to Stanford or the valley or
Boulder or Austin so we have grandeur in
that way okay good I'm a consultant
remember better ask questions on the
tree hi yes what do you think about
approaching the omg's with sort of like
a typical Chinese model or what's
existing someplace else where what
you're really doing is taking an
existing entrepreneurial Airbnb well or
something like that and doing something
that's a proven model and just exporting
or importing it to the Philippines well
they already have more money actually
for that so one of the OMG they have a
sort of corporate seed fund which is
only they'll invest in local stuff for
the conglomerate but the budget for
bringing startups from other countries
to the Philippines is 500 times bigger
than in that budget so I have to say
that in the Philippines nobody hates the
Philippines like a Filipino so it's kind
of hard to get people to invest in our
own country we're very much sadly not
like Korea we have a lot of colonial
mentality left over right but that also
means opportunity so some of the some
ways out of that of this wall between
the grant
VC and VC do you find it's really
completely depends on the particular
situation it's different every time or
are you finding some things that seem to
work the way the things that seems to
work is to get doctors to do injuries
medical doctors to be angel investors
for healthcare stuff because the average
you can't do that so much with Adly
because the average age of a Filipino
farmer is 57 and they're smallholder
farmers right so that's why stuff a lot
of stuff hasn't been modernized and
smallholder farmers fair the reason
they're so poor is that they're 18
middlemen between them and me buying the
tomato so which we're going to kill with
the satellite basically because then you
give them real-time agricultural prices
and you're kind of the cultural data so
hopefully I don't get shot you have yes
sir
I think you made the one of the most
interesting and wonderful presentation
here Thank You professor - is it I won't
question it when you first started how
did you recruiting those three other
people work with you convince them to in
your body so much men look like uh-huh I
think the important thing to realize
about recruiting for startup in the
Philippines is that you don't just sell
the person but a lot of people coming
out of college wanted to join the firm
their parents wouldn't let them and I
know that sounds strange to you guys
because at 18 you're like out of the
house vermin you know but for us we're
very we're very close-knit Society so
I'll actually have parents tell that
tell them like look if you're going to
pay my son or daughter I mean I do know
how much I paid to send them to college
and then you're going to pay them just a
little bit more than minimum wage if
there's going to be satisfied with that
they should work for the family business
so I actually had to sell not just pitch
to the
applicant so I was one pitching I was
when recruiting I had to sell I'd have
dinner with their family or their spouse
as the case may be
or their girlfriend or fiance or
boyfriend you know as the case may be so
it was how I did it with great
difficulty it was very very great
difficulty fortunately I was able to
slow certain people and it worked right
so is there going to be a big change
between hybrid I'm and ignite month well
the very big change is that first most
people in my country will be able to
pronounce the company name which was a
big mistake on my part when I named it
in my pool I blame the margaritas that
the big change I guess would be the
structure we're incorporating it here in
the United States and then having
original operating headquarters in the
Philippines so that the Diaspora can
invest and since we have 255
congressional districts someone from the
south of the country can actually say I
want to invest in my hometown not in
your life generic part of your city
cities our alumni we're sure it's great
you have rice you have cleaning up the
water from the mining accident 20 20
years ago what do you feel like
investing in so it's it's not that it's
not it that's gonna be one of the
changes but essentially a lot of these
people we've been working with them
anyway so except that now I guess on our
day to day basis we actually have more
power that's the problem being a
consultant it's like being a parent if I
just don't do that don't do that you did
it
it's okay come to mama mama she loves
you it's okay we'll fix it mama yeah you
know now we can take nope yeah so that's
a little bit better we can we can have
things off at the pass I think it should
be good so you had reached something
like 17 thousand entrepreneurs was that
a good number yes and I'm curious are
you doing a lot of short-term training
programs people apply to be part of or
now how do you what kind of ways are you
reaching
people what kind of ways are we reaching
the people Facebook okay
well seriously because we are a
mobile-first country the average number
of mobile phones per Filipinos - because
the internet is so bad so it depends
where you have signal right i know i
whatever i'll call anything the province
that doesn't have LTE
right it's like 3g all right then of
course and if there's no polka stop and
i'm like god I'm in the boonies so but
when you have the like I think like what
after being is where the were than like
second nationality that's on Facebook so
a lot of people will just come up and we
make them ridiculously cheap I actually
got into trouble at the last web summit
because people said you know all of the
young global leaders you should at least
be charging $5,000 for speaking and I'm
like yeah I do it for free
right because my teaching philosophy is
that if you get them young ish and if
you're entertaining enough that they
stay awake they'll probably stand the
chance of learning something
so I actually go around the country
we're doing it for free and I've done
that for a long while and it's helped
with the Millennials call it personal
branding so they actually then think ah
this chick actually knows something and
then they start up something then they
end up paying me yes
Christina pardon yes I had this sort of
thing doesn't work completely then I'm
coming back here and you know getting
runs on all of her and you know yeah
that's a backup career right ah anyone
yes sir
what is your personal family's life like
are you married you have kids yes I used
to be married I used to be married into
a really really great person you still a
really really great person but no I
don't have kids
much to the horror of my mother
my dad I'm a great disappointment but I
actually don't believe so much in
work-life balance and this sounds
strange but that is because most people
think that work is that like like there
is no love or life in your work and I
love doing what I do so much so I don't
consider it a job when my Dean at the
Ocean Institute of Management says but
now when you need is money forward are
paying you love to teach and I'm like
huh you're not paying me to teach you're
paying me to check papers I hate that
right but and that also acts as if life
doesn't take work you want to have a
solid marriage it takes work right you
want to raise well Advaita be
well-adjusted children then it takes
work so I just feel like it's energy
management because a start-up doesn't
actually require 100% of your time it
requires most of your time probably but
if you come home and this is what I
discovered badly if you come home and if
you have no energy right then things are
going to fill up things are going to
give right so I think that I'm still not
a believer in work/life knowledge it's
about energy management for me be and
actually learning to be present present
for other people right not just your
spouse that your family like I have my
dad was the fifth of ten children I have
like 80 cousins just on my father's side
so it's a struggle so oh one more
question I'm sorry if there is one thing
maybe an ecosystem that needs to change
to accelerate the growth having more
entrepreneurs handling in the country
what do you think that would be like
this I wouldn't I would undo the
nineteen shareholder rule the
Philippines Securities and Exchange
Commission has the nineteen shareholder
rule which means that after the nineteen
shareholder you have to register every
single share and it's tedious and odious
and it prevents crowdfunding right
because a lot of call center people lots
of middle-class people they and they
love the country
they understand the opportunity there
scientifically and technologically
literate but I can't take money from
them because I'll get arrested right
because ask nineteen shareholders it
will not make financial sense to keep I
can't do crowdfunding not even for my
equity I could take donations but people
are going to get donation fatigue right
so that's some batchest equality it can
be undone with the wave of pen so I'm
slowly inching my way to the FEC
chairman to try and convince it maybe
that's a good thing also you know a
bunch of other little policies it can be
undone but if I had to pick one that's
what I would do so one last question yes
and then we'll all go out and have some
refreshments outside of you've been
doing this a while are you seeing
changes what kind of you know if you
were to compare this year to three years
ago to six years ago what kind of
changes would you say you're seeing in
the ecosystem I think that because of
start-up fever a lot more people want to
start businesses they just don't know
how to do that
anyways or startup fever oh no there's
there's like startup dengue all right
it's not even a fever anymore it's like
I'm going to do a startup what is it
it's going to be like Airbnb only in the
Philippines okay why right so it's a I
think there's definite startup fever
there's more people interested in
investing in startups but not
necessarily good to be on a start-up
board so there's a lot of need for
education for training for information I
think but also there are a couple of US
veterans as well from the actual
innovative tech startup world and the
sad thing I'm seeing because it's grown
a bit is that we now spend more time
talking at other people instead of
talking to each other and saying dude
what do you need no I know someone like
that I'll hook you up with Christina
it you need to eat someplace - not some
place to stay but like I need a
developer for this I need you know
funding for my movie and like okay
because we don't spend enough time
anymore where before we'd be drowning
our sorrows in milk of course
clean-living
yes so yeah we would always see each
other and now that's not the case so
much anymore but that's a good thing
because that's part of growth of the
ecosystem so if I was going to just
leave people with everything since it's
the last question
maybe the Philippines is not on your
radar maybe the Philippines is just
someplace you heard about today maybe
you don't have the money to come visit
you should it's really more fun in the
Philippines but the thing you should do
actually is think about surfing not just
surfing in my country but surfing in
general why invest you don't catch your
way when it's that high right you sit on
your surfboard you paddle out there and
you wait and you have to catch the wave
when it's going up right so and not just
the Philippines but the Southeast Asian
region it's coming up so you should
start looking into it by the way you
don't need to learn bahasa or any other
language because we all speak some form
of English okay so come to my country
we'll be fine thanks thank you very much
Oh